hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach okay I loaded up my
old save so I'm just gonna try this
again and hopefully not lose everything
I say I'm going to keep the gas masks
because I don't know if I'll if that'll
go anywhere okay definitely set it from
one two one two very fine and kuszleika
get it get it get it get it get it get
it get it get it get it get it get it
get it get it
flick-flick flick-flick flick-flick
flick-flick flick-flick come on come on
Oh bull a bull that's bull that's bull
mark upon man everybody knows I can do a
360 noscope headshot from across the
room let's try this individually
hopefully this will work
I think I think putting multiple things
in that time kind of screws it up a
little bit
yes is that the Omni guard yes yes right
now let's do the sat-nav and yes yes
crunch it up
mash abusive
yes ultimate yes ah very good
yeah very good and now let's do the gas
mask because I know I know that I think
this actually works let out
down if I put this on huh oh wait what
well I guess it runs up wait a minute oh
there goes it I stopped losing speed
I mean I stopped losing sprinting juice
I have on limo Ted on your bow Ted yeah
all right fine
get that off don't need save let's get
out of air
carry on I don't know later but we're
gonna move forward oh yeah back where we
first got the key ah
shove it why why
why why you do that
poof fast speed you're in there I sail
huh okay come on get you will get you
will get okay
I bet yeah oh yeah Wow what I got them I
got them cover I don't remember where I
saved but I got past them
see you now don't go the [ __ ] anywhere
Dom moving thank you Godley but that was
all about I thought I was in the clear
okay back here now I move forward
hopefully safety I don't know about
safety but you know I'll be able to get
some blue what's into why that's so dark
really dark here oh yeah is where I
found the totes awesome
SC 3 4 20 mm mm all right the walkie
duct
okay nothing there all right
nothing yet that's what the nuke note is
that's where the card but I don't need
that card anymore okay we're good we're
good we can move on move wine why is
that black I don't know why that
blackness just keeps popping up out of
nowhere
what nope nope nope no no I know that's
crap
oh that's a big old trap by the biggest
eyes super trap I mean it was I was
obvious but I didn't obviously fell for
it before I don't know what
huh ah what does that mean is he here
hey open the door Judy I don't know why
is that I was that freaking me out more
than anything man
what does that mean
Oh No oh there is there is okay I see
him okay right on the outer edge or
enter it I'm not sure but see you here
we go now York I see I see everybody
don't like that don't know like that I
know like that I know like that at all
oh this elevator
I think they fixed this let me go down I
updated my
I'm not gonna save in the uh no no
radical Aries nu I'm gonna run with my
guys no gun they can run forever
can't see anything
not going in there again how do I the
door here I'm not going down there
that's for damn sure
that's for damn sure I'm not going down
there again
up high mr. STP man whoa I can't my time
be over high around you
hahaha why
pretty good I don't want to know what
that is I really don't
I'm not going at the tunnel again Oh yep
hi floatie hey thump I I'm gonna oh no
not the low frame rates I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm going to
die I'm going to die
I'm on de amor de moda oh my god it's
about that time when my game is gonna
crash oh god I can't I can't even move
okay let's hope that helps where that's
happened before my game a game crisis
not if that goes there go game crush
game growth Abraham every access
violation whatever I don't care
all right let's see traps in three two
one
boom boom
ah some like a memory access violence I
don't want to go in the tunnel I don't
want to go at something I don't want to
go I don't want to go I don't want to go
I don't want to go in to tell I don't
want to go oh I see p17 oh you're such
an a-hole I don't want to be down here
oh I don't want to be down here
Yankees oh that's right it'll Larry nope
Oh not happening can't see [ __ ] I have
no hope all hope is lost
all right okay I'm just gonna do this
I'm gonna put on the map a wagon sprint
I'm just gonna follow the roots of
legging
no no I don't know can't see anything
oh I love that okay run gone can't see
anything can't see anything can't you
can't see anything still can't see can't
see probably haven't go forward as
radical Larry can't see I'm dead I don't
know I don't know I don't know what do
why did he just baby he's right on top
of me somewhere I don't know where
though okay no ah bollocks got my eye on
you
no dork dork dork dork sure come on not
fair
not fair it's not fair
all right I'm all hot I'm all right so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotations over
there for more let's plays that I've
done check out my reaction compilations
thank you again and as always we'll see
you in the next video bye bye